should bring the water up from the ocean
percolated through a filter to remove
the solids that are floating in the
water
another finer filter to remove even
smaller solids and then last step we go
through the reverse osmosis membrane
so this is the most energy-intensive
water supply option with the most
greenhouse gas emissions so we know that
climate change is largely caused by
greenhouse gas emissions in carbon
building up in our system you know it
requires a lot of energy to pump water
here from Northern California right now
we use it once send it to the ocean and
they're going to use even more energy to
desalinate it and drink it again we call
that the cycle of insanity